mission impossible fallout runs for an
amazing 147 minutes and is jam-packed
with awesome action scenes and stunning
moments but there were even more great
scenes cut from the final movie yippie
Kay may be lovers it's Jan here and in
this video I'm revealing the top 10
deleted and censor scenes you never got
to see in Mission Impossible 6 including
White Widow in cashmere fake trailer
shots and helicopter near collisions
spoilers ahead if you haven't seen the
movie or add this video to a watch later
playlist and come back when you're ready
one scene from the trailers which fans
were really hoping to see but which
didn't make it into the final movie was
where Ethan's helicopter was going full
pelt into an oncoming truck on a forest
road this scene would have appeared
during the already packed helicopter
chase sequence between Ethan and Henry
cavils Walker and I think could have
been during one of the moments were
Ethan's chopper was spiraling out of
control given how close the chopper and
truck come to colliding I have loved
have seen how Ethan got himself out of
this one in the movie after the halo
jump in Paris we see crews and cobble
land on the roof of the Grand Palais but
a further stunt sequence filmed inside
the Palais was Kurt the deleted scene
featured crews swinging from a rope over
the crowd and was rejected by writer
director Christopher McQuarrie because
although it looked pretty cool the film
was already running long and it wasn't
necessary for the story while the movie
gives us a number of big fight scenes
inside the Grand Palais another smaller
one this happened outside the venue was
given the chop in the final film after
ethan and white widow exit the building
next thing we know they're in the back
of a car together but there's a deleted
scene before that car ride where Ethan
gets into a fight with white widows
brother Zola and smashes his head
against a car which actually left actor
Fredrik Schmitt with a black eye
I imagine this moment was ditched in the
editing room as it didn't move the plot
forward but merely reinforced the
animosity we'd already witnessed earlier
when Zola warned Ethan not to touch his
sister actress Vanessa Kirby told MTV
that the car ride with White Widow and
Ethan was part of a much longer and now
deleted scene where in her words things
got a bit fruity between them in the
cutscene White Widow talked about how
she enjoyed having blood on her dress
from the knife fight earlier in the
parlez this deleted scene would have
further played up the flirtation between
her and Ethan and would have also been a
callback to the car ride that Ethan took
with Max in the first Mission Impossible
movie in case he missed it max was
revealed to be white widows mother in
this film and I explained that in more
detail in my Mission Impossible 6
connections and ending video this
gorgeous scene of Ethan White Widow and
Walker marching through a Hall of
Mirrors was in the movie however an
alternate shot of Ethan and Ilsa walking
down the hallway was never used
McQuarrie has said that shot of Tom
Cruise and Rebecca Ferguson was never
meant to be in the movie and was
specifically filmed as something cool
for the trailers there was also a big
fight scene with Ilsa cut from the film
and hopefully we'll get more details on
that on the blu-ray the trailers also
teased numerous shots in the final act
set in Kashmir which never made it into
the final film some of those shots hints
at some pretty dark moments with Ethan
Ilsa Benji and Luther encountering
murdered soldiers and aid workers at a
border checkpoint the scene seems to go
on with Ethan approaching the door to a
bunker opening it and descending some
stairs where I suspect he would have
discovered further horrors it's unclear
whether the murders they discover are
the actions of Walker or Solomon Lane
some Indian viewers suspect these
specific border scenes might have been
cut to avoid controversy in India as the
Kashmir region which geographically
spans India Pakistan and China is one of
the most militarized areas of the world
and has long-running border and
separatist conflicts in fact Mission
Impossible fallout has already been
censored by India's Film classification
Board or mentions of Kashmir have been
cut from the Indian release of the movie
including dialogue the title card that
comes on screen when the region first
appears and other scenes have also been
trimmed director Christopher McQuarrie
has said that any deleted trailer scenes
was simply cut because the movie was too
long which sounds perfectly reasonable
given the film's long runtime though I
wonder if in this instance political
considerations also played a part
there's some curious behind-the-scenes
footage of white widow actress Vanessa
Kirby on the set in New Zealand where
the Kashmir scenes were filmed white
widow never appeared in Kashmir in the
final film so I wonder whether there was
originally a story where the handover of
Solomon Lane that she brokered was
actually going to take place there one
of the more meta moments in Fallout
comes when
henry cavill x' walker angrily r Solomon
Lane why do you have to make everything
so complicated originally McQuarrie
planned for this line to part for much
longer segment where everything in the
movie was explained Walker's backstory
what happened to the plutonium and so on
but test audiences hated it and thought
it was tedious so it was cut I can
understand why this exposition was
removed as fans enjoyed the Mission
Impossible movies not only for their
incredible action scenes but also for
their twists and turns these work best
when the audience isn't too confused but
doesn't know everything that's going on
and so it's about getting that right
balance curiously absent from the IMF
team this time around after having
appeared in the previous two movies was
Jeremy Renner's William Brandt in an
interview with Digital Spy McQuarrie
explained that when the movie started we
didn't really have a screenplay so it
was very difficult for us to say who
would be in the movie for how long and
on what days and Renner had a commitment
to Marvel if we had a finished script we
would have been able to say yes this
will work and we can let you go for this
time but there was just no predicting
what those roles were going to turn out
to be it was just an unfortunate case of
bad timing admittedly renas role in
rogue nation was scaled back to a
smaller supporting part than the one he
had when he started the franchising
ghost Protocol so it seems natural he
would have given priority to Marvel and
of course he'd obviously have to honor
the contract he signed with them
however the worst part is as Marvel fans
know that hawkeye never even appeared in
Avengers infinity war so instead of
appearing in two of the biggest films of
2018 rena played tag with Jon Hamm Ed
Helms Hannibal Buress and Jake Johnson
instead Avengers 4 did shoot
back-to-back with infinity war though so
hopefully he does have a decent part in
that movie and assuming Renner does want
to return I think we'll see Brandt back
in Mission Impossible 7
speaking of which although I feel full
at position CIA boss Erica Sloane is the
likely successor to Handley France did
work closely with Handley in rogue
nation so it's possible he could take
over as the IMF new secretary though
that probably wouldn't be the most
interesting role for his character and
might be disappointing to fans who would
like to see him return to active duty
funny trailer moment was cut from the
scene when Benji Ethan and Luthor were
waiting to make the plutonium trade this
is a bad idea is
good one honestly so do you wish any of
these deleted scenes had been in the
film and were does fall out ranked on
your list of favorite Mission Impossible
movies let me know in the comments below
tap left to discover all the ways
fallout connects with the other movies
plus how it sets up ni7 or tap right for
my full movie deleted scenes playlist if
you enjoyed this video I always
appreciate a thumbs up and a share
thanks for watching and see you next
time you began movie lovers